a Galadriel and a seal door really that
tall are all of durin's folk clones
let's see if the rings of power stay
true to tolkien's vision
in Peter Jackson's a Lord of the Rings
The Fellowship of the Ring Frodo and the
rest of the fellowship are forced to
flee through the cavernous ruins of
Kazar Doom in an exciting chase scene
that culminates in Gandalf going up
against a terrible balrog in the rings
of power viewers get to see this Grand
dwarf and city in its prime the ruler of
Kazar Doom is king do in the third
played by Peter Mullen One of the
dwarves known as durian's Folk do in the
third is one of the seven to receive a
ring of power he has gray hair and a
luxuriously long beard of a similarly
Steely Hue which suggests he's getting
on in years during the time in which the
rings of power takes place he also wears
a spiked metal crown and fine robes
befitting his high station there is no
physical description of King durin III
in tolkien's work although it is said in
the appendices of The Lord of the Rings
that do in the third looks remarkably
like his ancestor durin the first in
fact each new son born of do win's line
looks so much like the original durian
that all of them are thought to be
reincarnations of the first mullen's
appearance augmented by impressive
Prosthetics is so genuinely dwarf-like
that is easy to picture the books during
the third looking exactly like him
the son of King do in the third in the
show is Prince Duren IV played by actor
Owen Arthur in the official trailer for
the rings of power do in the fourth can
be seen with the dwarf princess diesa
who tells him earnestly that Kaza Doom
will be his to rule one day the context
of this brief clip isn't known as of yet
but we can speculate that the Young
Prince may be reluctant to take his
father's place on the throne we can also
guess that there may be a divide between
Father and Son as king do in the third
has some foreboding words for his son I
am sorry but their time has gone who
exactly the king is referring to is as
yet a mystery but it's distinctly
possible that the prince may be pleading
with his father to Aid The Elves and men
in the war against Sauron and the King
Duren III has chosen to abstain
according to tolkien's writings all of
durin's descendants have a remarkable
resemblance to him which includes durian
IV the prince has thick red hair that
sticks out at the end and a long
voluminous beard that is planted into a
single braid it's possible that Dew in
the fourth is a spitting image of King
durin the third in his youth before his
old age caught up with him
hi King gilgallard played by actor
Benjamin Walker as an important role in
the story The Rings of power tells he is
the high King of the race of elves known
as the nildor or the Deep elves gilgalat
is mentioned in many of tolkien's Works
including the simarillion and the Lord
of the Rings as well as later works
published by his estate including the
history of Middle Earth and the nature
of Middle Earth in these books gilgalad
is witness to many of the great battles
of the war of belarian in which the
Elves leave their home of valinor to
pursue morgoth and reclaim their silma
rails he is much too young to fight at
this time however and so he has moved to
safety along with his mother by his
father orodrath after becoming King in
the realm of Linden gilgalad joins with
Lendale of Gondor and the fight against
Sauron forming the last Alliance of
elves and Men that's one time gilgalad
held two rings of power one of which he
gave to elrond the description of
gilgalad and the books is vague but the
nature of Middle Earth describes Elven
King as being notably tall and having
lustrous silver hair in the rings of
power gilgalad has long dark brown hair
why the makers of the show decided to
change this aesthetic detail is unknown
those stickers for accuracy May slight
them for it
memorably played by Hugo weaving in The
Lord of the Rings and topic movies the
rings of power features a much younger
elrond this incarnation of the character
portrayed by actor Robert aramayo is a
long way away from becoming the wise
leader of Rivendell movie fans know and
love let me meet our run and the rings
of power he is a loyal follower of High
King gilgalad he is also close friends
with Galadriel and wishes for her to
retire her Warrior ways following the
victory against the dark lord morgoth
tolkien's a Fellowship of the Ring gives
a very poetic description of elrond's
appearance the face of elrond was
ageless neither old nor young although
idiots was written the memory of many
things both glad and sorrowful his hair
was dark as the shadows of Twilight and
upon it was set a circlet of silver his
eyes were gray as a clear evening and in
them was a lie to light the light of
stars in the rings of power young girl
runs as wavy brown hair and brown eyes
as opposed to hair as dark as shadows
and strikingly gray eyes he might not
fit the exact physical description of
the character from the books but then
this is a younger version of the
character who has not seen the horrors
yet to be inflicted by the wicked Sauron
the young Galadriel of the Rings of
power is played by morvet Clark while
fans of the Peter Jackson movies may
know her as one of the most powerful
elves in existence and the lady of
loflorian the Amazon Prime series takes
place many years in the past here
Galadriel is a hardened fighter fresh
off the battlefield in the war against
morgoth the soul Marillion and
unfinished Tales tell how Galadriel and
other noldor elves along with
galadriel's brothers and cousins leave
the lands of valinor and sail to Middle
Earth after meeting and Marian
kellerborn Galadriel and her husband are
given Reign Over The Elven Kingdom of a
region by High King gilgalad it isn't
until later that kelleborn and Galadriel
leave a region to become Lord and Lady
of lovelorian Galadriel is described in
the books as being exceptionally tall
six feet four inches to be exact and
having gray eyes but it is galadriel's
hair that has a crowning Glory
unfinished Tales describes her Tresses
as gold and silver reminiscence of the
two trees of valinor feyenoor creator of
the summer rails is so enraptured by the
beauty of her hair that he begs
Galadriel for a lock of it three times
each time she refuses why do you keep
fighting there is a tempest in me in the
rings of power Galadriel has long wavy
pale blonde hair she's much shorter than
her literary counterpart tolkien's
galadrio stands above most elves while
the series Incarnation is of more
typical stature she may not be a perfect
for simile but Clark's Galadriel is
still an ethereal being brimming with
ageless presence
the elf Keller brimbor makes his first
on-screen appearance in the rings of
power Keller brimbora is a descendant of
feyenoor who led the elves on their
first journey to Middle Earth he is a
veteran of many battles and the first
stages war against morgoth as Tolkien
Fanatics know well Keller brimbor is
also the legendary Smith who forged the
three rings of power for the elves in
the Amazon Prime series Keller brimbor
is currently the Lord of Aragon who is
working closely with the dwarves of
Kazar Doom this Alliance is beneficial
to both sides as Keller brimbor is
considered a master Craftsman and the
dwarves are renowned for their excellent
Smiths notably it is Keller brimbor who
encourages the dwarves to begin the
mining of mithril the precious metal
that resides within the mountains of the
Dwarven Kingdom there is no physical
description of Keller brimbor offered in
tolkien's various Works however as he's
one of the noldor elves we can
reasonably assume that Keller brimbor
shares their classic characteristics
these elves are known for their clear
gray eyes and strikingly dark air in the
rings of power Keller brimble has light
brown hair which seems to be graying
very slightly at the edges as far as
accuracy goes this look seems to go
against tolkien's law but of course this
assumes Keller brimbor of the books
possesses all the typical features of
his people
the rings of power introduces queen
regent Muriel of numenor played by
Cynthia Adai Robinson Muriel is meant to
succeed to the throne after the death of
her father King tarpalantia however her
cousin farazone usurps the throne and
takes her as his wife tolkien's books do
not give a physical description of
Muriel but because Muriel is one of the
dunadine we can assume she said a chance
of inheriting her people's
characteristic dark hair as portrayed by
a die Robinson Muriel is a Regal figure
she has long elaborately styled dark
hair brown skin and dark brown eyes her
garments are among the most resplendent
in the rings of power constructed of
Rich Fabrics shining beads and
glimmering metals her accessories are
especially impressive her Golden Crown
resembles dazzling Flames while a bright
Medallion Shines on her chest
Farah zone is the last king of numenor
before the realm is destroyed as
mentioned in tolkien's books he is a
great soldier who forced and won many
battles throughout the land notably he
shares the wealth he's accumulated from
his victories with the people of numenor
which earns him massive support and
respect from the population
unfortunately Farah's own success also
makes him vain Vino and greedy he
disagrees with his uncle tarpalantia on
many fronts especially regarding his
friendship with the elves of Middle
Earth upon the King's death the pharah's
own steals the throne from his cousin
miriel whom he proceeds to marry to
solidify his claim he then plunges to
new depths when he breaks the alliance
with the elves even going so far as to
forbid the Elven language from being
spoken in the kingdom when we meet
pharah's own in the rings of power he
seems to have put his Warrior days well
behind him having traded battle scarred
armor for extraordinarily fine robes
this far as own as long hair and a full
beard which have both grown salt and
pepper are colored with advancing age
tolkien's books don't tell readers what
pharah's own looks like precisely versus
numenorian blood implies he probably has
dark hair that would indeed graze the
years go on
CE the high King of the Duna died in
Middle Earth a land deal is an ancestor
of Aragorn when tensions Brew in numenor
following pharah's own's Ascension to
the throne a lendil foresees grim
Tidings on the horizon in response he
sails with his son isildor and a group
of numenoreans known as the faithful
with a fleet of ships headed for Middle
Earth When A lender and his people land
in Middle Earth the allies with high
King gilgalad Of The Elves together they
lead an army of men and elves against
Sauron and fight valiantly side by side
at the siege of Baroda the prologue of
The Fellowship of the Ring depicts this
great battle in which alendil dies at
saron's hand and his legendary sword
martial is broken according to tolkien's
work a lendil is very tall that's
written in unfinished Tales he clocks in
at a massive 7 feet 11 inches none of
the characters other physical traits are
described but we do know that he's of
numenorian descent which means we can
assume that the book's version of the
character likely has dark hair and gray
eyes in the rings of power alendil has
shoulder length dark brown hair and a
trim beard as well as blue eyes this is
a pretty accurate likeness to that
implied by the books even if his eyes do
set him apart
most fans are the Lord of the Rings film
Trilogy will recall a seal door as the
man who betrays his people when he
chooses to keep the one ring for himself
rather than throw it into the fires of
Mount Doom destroy it no
however the Eco door we meet in the
rings of power is just a normal teenager
still a long way off from the Fateful
actions that led to the events of the
Lord of the Rings it's thanks to a seal
door that the famous white tree is
rescued from destruction by King
farazone according to the silmarillion a
jungi seal door steals fruit from the
tree which he then plants the fruit
grows into a sapling the sapling goes on
to Bear the seeds that eventually grow
into the white Tree of Gondor a seal
door then sails away from numenor with
his father alendil to Middle Earth after
arriving in the southern region of their
new land isildor and his brother are
narian found the kingdom of Gondor the
books don't tell us why isior door looks
like but we can probably guess that he
inherited his father's dark hair and
light eyes in the scholarly book The
Lord of the Rings a reader's companion
it is suggested that a seal door was
tall like his father possibly over seven
feet
[Music]
foreign
[Music]